we're going to turn overseas now where
the earthquakes in turkey and Syria one
week ago are now among the deadliest of
the century and there have of course
been miraculous rescues like the
four-year-old girl pulled from the
rubble look at those pictures but of
course those are the exceptions
officials say the confirmed death toll
has now risen to more than 35 thousand
people mcis tayab is in southern turkey
for us
the city of hatai has suffered the worst
of the worst
but even with destruction on a scale
that's hard to Fathom these men say they
won't stop searching even after a week
rescue workers say they hope they'll
find survivors but more often than not
they're finding bodies
like the remains of this mother and
daughter yet more victims of this
incomprehensible tragedy
for those left to look for something
warm to wear donated clothing are left
in piles on the street but none of this
is a substitute for what the people of
hatai a once prosperous City no longer
have
it's a tragedy that has turned grief
into rage this man is smashing the logo
of a well-known Construction Company who
he blames for shoddy construction work
that led to these buildings collapse so
this used to be your home yeah yeah but
for rfcd koglu he doesn't have time to
be angry as we stand on what used to be
his family's home he says he's too busy
looking for loved ones well we have
found our grandmother here yesterday but
we cannot find our grandfather
incredibly survivors have to pay out of
their own Pockets to run and fuel these
diggers you will not stop until you find
your grandfather Yeah of course we'll
dig with my with our hands now this
morning the UN announced that its rescue
phase is coming to a close David and
that it will instead start providing
things like food water and shelter which
is small Comfort to people like Arif who
desperately cling onto hope of finding
their loved ones under all this Rubble
MTS thank you